à anne k reen bailleur n'est un
copenhague signes du zodiaque entre
viège et ben alors c'est vrai c'est vrai
tu crois que tu es plus près de la
vierge de la balance la balance la
balance qui mesure 1 mètre 70
oui tu pèse 52 kilos pendant un moment
donné griffé quoi aussi cheveux châtains
foncés
c'est vrai nom châtain clair ah oui aux
yeux bleus we will change c'est un feu
vert dont ils sont clairs de signe
particulier une grande manche domicile
quartier latin c'est vrai c'est ça oui
pour tes admirateurs lui avenches les
maisons de campagne pas encore la mienne
alors alors dis-moi vie privée situation
de famille degré d'instruction
établissements scolaires langues
français anglais danois suédois italiens
italien connaissait depuis gardons les
actrices à quelques actrices ont regardé
ce mystère ont gardé quelque chose de
vraiment réelle personnalité et à la
haye l'a vraiment avoir activement pas
toi d'abord un nom c'est vrai alors
c'est important est là un mystère
elle est quelqu'un c'est une c'est une
plante elle bouge elle l aime la vie
elle est vivante à la dgde regardé comme
années elle a des yeux m
tout ça ça bouge tout le temps en fait
elle a fait de la danse elle sait bouger
à ces marchés c'est très important
c'est combien quelque chose quand même
non mais crois que c'est mon fiancé